turning now to an important update on
the cbs news investigation last month we
revealed that more than 30 u.s soldiers
who were injured in iraq in an iranian
missile attack had been denied the
purple heart senior investigative
correspondent katherine herrich broke
this story for cbs mornings she joins us
now from the pentagon catherine what's
the latest
nate after our team contacted the
pentagon the army initiated a new review
and yesterday the soldiers learned their
awards had been approved some soldiers
got a personal phone call telling them
their nearly two year wait for
recognition is over
that's awesome retired captain jeffrey
hanson was still taking phone calls from
his soldiers when we sat down wednesday
it's definitely a sense of relief and a
sense of recognition that i think that
they definitely deserve to feel we first
spoke with hansen last month along with
haley webster michael pridgeon and dane
casauger they were all diagnosed with
traumatic brain injuries after living
through this
the january 2020 attack on their base in
iraq
days earlier the u.s killed the powerful
iranian general qasim sulaimani the
ballistic missile strike in response
would be the biggest against american
forces in history everything shook
the whole earth shook felt like an
earthquake and then just pressure
moving through your body these are my
hearing aids cassagra and the group took
the unusual step of going on the record
after dozens of soldiers in their unit
were denied the purple heart what
message has the army sent to the
soldiers who were injured
your sacrifice was insignificant and
it's not
worth consideration which i don't
understand
59 soldiers appeared to meet the purple
heart criteria a hostile foreign force
launched the attack and their traumatic
brain injuries were long-lasting but
only 23 soldiers were recognized with
the award what happened to the rest we
got no response we actually were told to
not ask that question after the strike
the soldiers told us there was pressure
to downplay the growing number of
injuries to avoid a further escalation
with iran and to avoid undercutting than
president trump's initial comments i
heard
that they had headaches
and a couple of other things but i would
say
and i can report it is not very serious
what the president at the time said that
that very much diminished
the service of so many soldiers on
wednesday the army approved an
additional 39 purple hearts among them
corporal jason quittiqua
diagnosed with a traumatic brain injury
in october quittiqua took his own life
struggled you know like we all are like
i am the purple heart carries lifetime
benefits including priority medical care
at va hospitals what do you want the
army leadership to know eternal
gratitude they did a thorough review
they did it very quickly
and they you know sprung to take care of
the soldiers you know and that's that's
huge
hanson told us he believes this would
not have happened without the cbs news
reporting and more than 65 purple hearts
this attack may turn out to be one of
the single largest awards in recent
history another 11 service members are
being considered
on a case-by-case basis scale
boy catherine kudos to you for sharing
the story bringing the story to us it
clearly made a difference purple heart
represents so much thank you again